Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Oh,
all right,
Jean.
Here we are.
Here we are,
and here we go and aware we're off to this.
I just saw Fifo humping bitsy.
Very rare in this.
Doesn't happen a lot.
It doesn't happen.
You have a high libido.
We thought we had.
Absolutely not.
We thought we had a genderless sex list.
Asexually asexual animal many years.
He was.
We got his nuts off and he never heard anything.
Never.
But today I know we got him fixed.
Right then we got,
of course we did.
Both of them are animals arrived to us fix.
No,
he did not.
He arrived to us with these big black balls.
Oh,
remember he had big black nuts and gets a huge for his little body.
He only weighs that's right because,
oh,
pants.
The first day that um,
we got FIFO.
He,
we,
he,
we walked him into our house and he was,
yeah.
Hi.
I'm Payton Lafferty and fall.
Huh?
That's right.
True story shelter named him Peyton Lafferty.
Right.
We had to change it and he,
oh,
he was like,
yeah,
I got these big black balls and I don't want you to suck on them.
We were like,
whoa.
They were so big.
And I remember he used to run and they would jangle.
It was actually very cute.
But no,
no.
He has no Bob,
no balls.
But he's just humping her.
He,
he gets anxious when other people are coming around.
Yeah.
I think she senses we're going to have a guest.
You think so?
Yeah.
No,
that's the only time he does it.
When he senses he,
it's chaos.
It's like when you are anxious or depressed and you masturbate compulsively,
or when you're on the road and you're depressed,
why are you telling everybody?
Yeah.
Isn't that everybody's thing?
Especially if you know,
like a red heads coming over,
then it happens more.
You don't think so?
I think so.
He gets excited over that.
I think he knows.
Yeah.
He's a huge fan of the guy that's coming today.
I know he watches all of his specials and yeah.
Big Huge Fan of ATC,
Eh,
you know,
fucking different guys out of their fucking minds.
Yeah.
You know,
so it's excite,
excite Amaz.
Anyways,
where we had a lot to cover.
Let's um,
let's get into,
okay.
Yes,
yes.
Oh yeah.
Alright.
You crazy.
Ball Hog and here we go.
Here we go.
The team did that like
testable electronic capsule to monitor gas levels are not human god when it's
paired with a pocket size.
Let's see her and the mobile phone APP,
the till reports tail wind conditions in real time as it passes from the stomach
to the colon.
Colon is Randy,
don't bring anyone in loving.
You're welcome.
Welcome.
Welcome to your mom's house
Kabuki.
So yeah,
I'm petting laugh on it about Baja bug.
That's my favorite series of all time.
I also like the name Peyton pay.
I laugh our day like it's such a white girl.
It's such a thing to make your more names.
I mean,
I know there's the old kind of,
wait a minute,
that's not her given God name.
You would never believe it,
but know your parents didn't destine you to become a pornography.
There's like three people that use their real name.
Yeah.
And everybody else obviously picks up performing name and the old joke,
you know it was like you pick like the name,
your first street or something stupid.
I mean what have you had to go out there right now and pick up Horne name?
Shit skiing,
easy to pronounce.
Easy to spell.
Easy.
Horrible,
horrible.
I'm such an idiot.
I should have changed my last name for like 15 years ago when they started stand
up,
but I couldn't find a suitable,
I just couldn't,
you know,
you could have,
I tried,
I wanted to be Christina Black,
but then there's Jack Black.
He was huge at the time.
Louis Black.
Oh right.
You know what I mean?
There's too many blacks like there was too many.
There are.
I know exactly what you mean.
There's just,
they're everywhere.
That coming into our cities,
there are too many people with that last name and that's what I wanted.
I just,
I couldn't think of something.
What would you name me now if he like,
give me another name besides to go.
Obviously I can't do that cause we're not the fucking bobsy twins of comedy.
I know you,
I dunno.
So lame.
Uh,
Delilah dog hunt.
That'd be one.
We'll be talking about this ticket seller,
Christina,
if you were doing porn and they,
and they do that thing before you're,
you're seeing,
you're seeing the guy,
the guy's like,
hey babe,
you look super hot.
And you're like,
that's,
and he's like,
what's your name and your like,
Delilah.
Doug Kahn.
Good,
Whoa,
let's see this thing.
I mean,
that does Pique your interest.
Now,
if somebody texted me right now,
you've seen this,
uh,
Delilah dog hunt,
I'd be like,
Whoa,
whoa.
What?
Like,
yeah,
she's a do a porno.
She's pretty fucking crazy.
I'd be like,
yeah,
of course.
She named herself dog hunt.
That's,
that is the craziest,
yeah,
that's,
she's wild for sure.
It's a Laila dog hunt.
It's so funny that they,
that the porno industry still insists on calling it things like scenes or Phil.
I know,
I love it.
I love
language thing that they do is that they call people outside of its citizens.
Oh right.
We're do that in comedy.
I,
yeah,
I know.
But it's just funny to me that like,
cause there is usually we think of civilians,
you think of the military.
So I think of,
I think of porn people thinking of themselves as,
I'm like really sacrificing the cultural elite.
Yeah.
Well these regular civilians,
they don't know the kind of thing that we do.
We're special.
We don't know anything about fucking yet.
Nobody does.
Yeah.
Civilians,
I'm gonna shoot my scene today.
It does help.
So I gotta go to work.
It's all about,
so yeah,
it's all psychological cause you've got to feel okay about being paid Lafferty.
The ball hog.
Yeah,
of course.
If you're like,
well I'm kind of technically so people around you normalize it.
Yes.
That's absolutely true.
Yeah.
So it's legitimize,
well I guess porn back of the day was showed in movie theaters,
which now you're just like,
could you even imagine going to us sitting in a full theater,
not jerking off like a whole room full of especially that now they have those
recliner chairs in theaters.
So it's like state of the art comfortable,
you know?
Yeah.
You can't have a blanket over,
you press a button to call the server and some of those exclusive theaters,
you know,
it'd be like,
I kind of need some more tissues.
You have to whisper.
I made a mess,
can I,
can I have the cup,
the cup cleaner?
But then they come cleaner will come around and wipe you off as he's just an old
guy and you're like,
it's like it's not erotic.
You're like,
oh man.
I been gaining come for 48 years.
He's got a filthy rag and he uses the same rag on every word tea.
He's like,
I came here,
I needed a job.
And they said,
Dean,
they come.
And that's how I get my list here.
I think come cleaners gotta be the worst job in the world.
I did it.
Oh,
that's right.
It's split.
I was a comm cleaner.
Yeah,
but not like,
not like in the movie theater.
No,
but it was nasty as fuck.
I did laundry where people just fun.
Um,
I had to mop the floor.
The hot tub.
People know there was this place called splash,
relaxation,
spa third street,
or watched this show blind date for some reason.
Excellent reference ended up at splash because I'll tell you why
it was monetary.
So what happened was,
so splash spa,
the relaxation spa.
So if you're,
you're unaware,
you go like,
oh,
maybe that's a spa.
That's what I thought when I went in there,
because that's what they're calling at a spa.
I imagined I go like,
I like spa.
That's when I first got here.
You know,
I like to relax,
to relax.
I like steam rooms.
You know,
like maybe I can get a discount on a massage.
So I figured,
you know,
I'll be like a towel boy.
Like the guys you see at a spa.
Sure.
I'm dressed up and wearing their little thing like can I get you a glass of
water or something?
So I get there.
Um,
and the guy gives us a tour.
I was with my friend chuck and we go in there and he's like,
oh,
it's hourly rentals of themed rooms.
So there's like the Barcelona,
I remember that garden Greek room and basically Greco Roman.
Yes.
A stupid call on is behind them with has like plants,
paintings on the wall and it has a hot tub and a bed.
And so what it does do is it,
it was just to rent now they would,
they would lean on the fact that this is like a date spot because there were
some people that wanted to do that as like a date,
like an exciting,
I'll just go to this,
but could you,
okay.
And this is my,
my thought always on blind date with Roger Lodge.
There are two horrendous first dates for me personally.
Number one,
the workout date.
Terrible.
Meet me at the gym and we'll put on our gym clothes and sweat.
Number two,
the Jacuzzi,
the Public Jacuzzi Day.
It's crazy.
I mean that's television.
It's growth.
They knew it was good TV and when I said monetary because it was cheap for a TV
production and they would,
I'm sure they were thrilled to have the publicity splash on every episode about
what should happen is people would come in and splash,
rent the rooms,
but the big thing was hookers.
Right.
Clearly so because it's also,
where else can you go for an hour?
Yeah.
Now when I got,
when the guy was hiring us and training us,
he told us people will come in and they'll ask you about getting a hooker.
Here it goes.
You cannot tell them.
You have to say like we don't do anything like that.
Like we don't provide the hook.
Right.
But you can bring,
you can bring a hooker,
but like you can't be like,
hey,
can you help them arrange a hooker to come here?
So man,
I,
I mean we lasted chuck last like three days.
I laughed like two weeks.
What kept you hanging in?
Like what was honestly,
it was just that I had a job.
Yeah.
So I was like,
but then like it was one of those things psychologically you break down because
it's gross and yeah,
so they used to have this policy that you will have to go,
you have to go to the room,
uh,
when all parties are there.
But imagine if you're meeting a hooker,
let's say you set it up and you don't like,
you're nervous,
right?
You're embarrassed that this is happening.
So I would see guys coming in,
they were like,
I'll take the whatever room.
I'm like,
okay.
And they're like,
I'd like to go there.
And I'd be like,
well,
this is the other person here.
Uh,
no,
they're going to meet me here.
I'm like,
are you have to wait until they get here?
And they would get like,
they're like,
I don't want to wait.
I just want to go in there.
I'm like,
I'm sorry.
It's policy.
Ah,
you'd see them just kind of like,
man,
I can't,
there's nothing I can do.
Like,
can,
I really don't want to be like waiting here and like,
I'm sorry.
That's like,
that's the policy.
And then like a couple of times I would see,
you know,
another guy would walk in and go,
Kevin Are you Mario?
And they'd be like,
okay.
And then you look at me like,
come on.
Okay.
And then I would take them to the room one time two guys or one guy had two guys
meet him there and they were in that room six minutes,
you know,
pay Lafferty,
hey Lafferty in there.
And there's like three use condoms of course.
But there was no actual policy at splash prohibiting.
No,
of course walking in the hot tubs of body fluid being expelled in the water.
I mean that was encouraged that that was,
that was the whole point of splash.
But we just couldn't,
you couldn't get the hookers for them that you could facilitate the meeting kind
of.
I mean,
you're just like,
you're renting a room.
Like I don't care what you do in there,
but a room that's also really unhygienic and really dangerous if everyone's
coming in the whirlpool ev every day.
I mean how many loads of Tj's were in those jacuzzis and then now you're going
to rent that Jacuzzi and second.
So unhygienic system for like chlorine and measuring the Ph balance.
Then we had this mop,
you had to mop,
cleaning thing and then you had to
bunch up all the linens and wash that.
I remember one time after every quarter,
no matter what,
even if they like didn't use the bed,
sure you still had to do it.
Um,
I remember one time this couple came in that was clearly like a real couple and
the guy was like place nasty.
I kept,
he kept saying that and a nasty as hell and she was like,
no,
it's going to be fun.
She was trying to have like a romantic night.
I take them to their room and like a minute later the guy calls the front desk
and I go,
yeah,
he's like,
it placed nasties helmet.
So I go down there and there was a pubic hair and I don't know in the sink or
something worse.
And I was like,
oh,
I had to pretend.
I was like,
aw man.
So I immediately cleaned it up and he was like,
no,
Nah,
of course.
And I'm assuming that's why splash got shut down was probably prostitution and I
dunno,
I think he actually probably just had a good run,
you know,
that place was,
he was,
it wasn't old,
but I mean,
when I moved here,
which was over more than 15 years ago,
he had all white hair and he was,
I had to be like in his sixties or something.
Oh,
I mean,
splash has been around probably,
I don't know if it got closed for that as much as it might have been.
Just the,
um,
growing up here,
splash was the punchline.
Like you take your day to splash.
Everybody knew that some nasty shit was going down.
You know,
that shows you when you're new somewhere,
you don't know.
Of course.
Yeah.
I just walked in there like,
I like spa.
I wish I would've known you right when you moved here,
God told you to run from splash.
Yeah.
It was so gross.
He was such a weird guy.
Clearly.
Could you imagine what a rough business to run.
He boasted about his friendship with Hugh Hefner and you know,
parties at the playboy mansion and all that stuff.
Douchey old guy and the girl out.
Oh yeah.
He's like the run down.
I get a lot of broads.
Oh yeah.
Gross.
Anyways,
we saw a movie.
Yeah,
I wanted to have fun the other day and we made the mistake of seeing the movie
the post.
Yeah.
It wasn't a fun movie.
I don't know why I thought it would be like,
it's a well constructed movie.
I'm like all the,
all the moving parts of a story are there as well.
You know,
it's well put together,
but it just,
I just didn't find it that exciting.
I felt like I felt like,
am I a dumb person because I'm not riveted by what's happening here.
Oh,
okay.
We can't,
we gotta.
We gotta stop for a moment and,
uh,
get our guests.
Will you make a note of where we stopped this conversation so we can talk
further about it?
Thank you.
Um,
all right.
We had to stop really quickly to get let our guest in and he's here now.
I know many of you know him from his,
uh,
many stand up comedy specials,
his hit show VH ones.
I love the 80 strikes back
fart is for family on Netflix.
It's old Billy red nuts.
Bill Burr.
What's going on here?
Third time,
second second,
I think a second.
He came back in the old school and I'm now here.
Thanks for coming over man.
Yeah,
lots of change with you.
You've,
you've uh,
I remember in the silver lake days you were just a young,
a young little man and now you're a younger person.
I wasn't,
I was well into my forties.
I'm just developing very slowly and delightful young man.
I'll take that.
I remember,
I like that a 43 year old I met bill.
Um,
I don't know if I mentioned this on the last one,
but I met,
I met him in person,
I'd seen him on Chappelle show and you know,
central and like at the height of its popularity.
And then I was at Melrose and this is like,
I don't know what it was.
It was the year that you moved here and he was at the bar and I just started
talking to him and he was like,
uh,
yeah,
you know,
I walked here and I go,
oh,
from wearing,
he goes,
silver lake walked here from silver lake.
He was like,
yeah,
it's kind of far.
And I go,
yeah,
uh,
and I still in a New York sorta see.
Yeah,
of course.
Which makes sense.
And he goes,
uh,
you know,
plus I wanted to be able to see a little bit of the city.
It's just like so much of it,
it's just like,
you know,
just go,
go,
go somebody up your acid,
you're trying to drive with something.
So,
and I gave him a ride back to his house and I was like,
this is way far for a walk.
And then right before he got out of the car,
he goes,
uh,
do you want to see me come?
And I was like,
alright.
And He,
you know,
he just jerked off and then he got out of the car.
This is a me too story.
What's the thing is like I was,
I was,
I wasn't effecting,
you weren't saying that.
I'm saying that.
I was like,
that's pretty cool man.
Then he goes,
that's the secret to be to being good at Sam.
Or I told you,
too many comics listened to me and now they're all getting in trouble.
But that is the secret for all.
You Young,
uh,
open miker is out there.
Kind of start doing it more.
Um,
we discovered that there's a weirdest story anybody's ever said that like made
me uncomfortable from the beginning.
Now it's the serial killer,
right tone,
like his complete lack of emotional scale.
This happened.
You know what?
And I know building missing from his stories is sound of somebody gagged,
screaming in the other room.
Right now I know that you,
and I know that you suspect that my husband is a psycho.
I've heard,
I've heard about,
yeah,
no,
I know.
And I've,
and I've been trying to prove this on this show for a loss like you don't have
is like bud,
this bud light.
There's like psycho and psycho light.
Like,
he just,
he's not the,
uh,
the high calorie one that can't get married and have kids.
Yes.
But if you,
if his thoughts were a movie.
Yeah,
definitely.
NC 17 he's a functioning psychopath.
Yeah.
You know why?
Because when I started dating him ball,
and this is a true story,
when I started dating Tom Segura back in oh five,
there were red flags,
little stuff like when we were little dead animals behind your apartment
building.
I remember,
you know,
in the beginning you're all lovey Dovey,
D and a,
and he'd be like,
I like you so much.
I just want to gouge your eyes out.
I want to squish your face and kill you and,
and put a sledge hammer in your hand and you're like,
I love you so much.
I just want to smash your God damn head in.
I'm being serious.
If somebody said that about my kid,
my time,
oh my God,
look at those feet.
I just want to cut them off.
And it was just like fucking lunatics.
Yeah.
Right there.
You can't,
you can't be with a person like that.
So we need a safe house.
We got a guest room.
Well I'm two kids deep now.
I think I used to say like,
I want to put your head through that.
Yeah,
yeah.
But I was like as an expression of love and there were other things too,
like cause you don't like love and you hate that and makes you feel weak or
something that you want to violently take it out on her.
That's exactly right.
Exactly right.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
it worked out.
It did actually.
You're frustrated that you knew you had no control over the love that you had
for your wife.
So then you just,
you starting to feel trapped.
I think it was more of like didn't know how to express how good I felt,
you know?
So I thought,
no,
he really just tried.
He tried to play like dimwitted they're
calculated you,
everything you need to be to make in this business.
You just can't keep creative and just be floating around like,
Oh that tickles my artistic fantasy.
You have to have a plan,
but you've got to leave your friends and family behind.
This is all these things.
When Oprah talks about women,
oh,
you're going to do this,
you got,
she leaves all that part out.
Yeah.
You're going to miss your children growing up.
Get to the top of the mountain and you're going to be alone and have no real
friends.
And there's a reason I never had children as Oprah because I,
I don't give,
I don't have time for that shit.
I wanted to fucking take over the world for a second.
Yeah.
We were swinging the sickle with both hands.
You mean you can't,
you can't carry a kid.
No,
I agree.
Yeah.
The other side of it,
of course you're talking about me,
is that there's a lot of people writing in that bill is,
you know,
a much more profound psycho.
No,
never seen it.
No.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't disagree with tight,
but I think that like,
he fits the,
uh,
it's,
I get away with it being a redhead,
so everybody thinks,
oh,
oop,
Ron Howard,
they think like,
oh yeah,
the guy who doesn't get the girl,
the,
uh,
the fucking awkward.
That's what they think him.
He looks like,
you know,
every time there's a fucking serial killer that is the exact hairline when they
lead them out,
that is CSC,
exact fucking hairline.
Well,
and also,
you know,
I'm a sweet guy,
Bill.
That's why you're an extra psycho.
And Bill deals with his anger on stage,
right?
You've got act.
It's parts of your act.
They're very,
the punching of the muffins,
it's very aggressive.
He deals with his anger creatively.
You suppress,
you pushed down,
you push down.
You start,
you're doing is you're,
you're looking at me on stage as if that's who I am.
Like you got to talk to my wife.
My wife lives with me and I,
yeah,
I'm a fucking lunatic.
Which you express the rage.
It comes out creatively,
at least is what it also comes out in his personal life.
Are you,
do you,
are you angry at home over the dumbest shit these stupidest.
What got you last time?
The hiatus.
It's blind,
right?
Like I see red,
so I don't remember just dumb shit.
Dumb Shit.
I don't remember.
I go to a garage and it's locked and I don't have my keys.
Yeah.
And I'll just scream of course.
And 1.3 houses down,
they'll hear it.
Can you imagine,
by the way,
she has this trait.
If you think I'm bad,
what?
How you would be with Mr Burger over here.
So if I drop my phone,
I go,
God dammit.
Right?
Like oh shit.
She goes,
what happened?
I dropped my phone.
Oh yeah.
No you wouldn't last.
Cause I had so much anger in my house growing up.
Everybody's fucking yelling all the time and I don't like it.
So why did you pick this lunatic?
Cause he doesn't rage.
It's,
it's under the SURPI suppresses it?
Yeah.
And then he'll let it out.
A one big spurt.
Like I'll,
I'll really piss them off and then he'll let it,
let me have it.
Let you have it.
It takes like a while.
What does let you have helped the dog?
You poke the dog.
You poke the dog and the dog eventually.
I don't bite really though.
I mean I bite like what?
I'm sure I'm way worse than him.
I don't know what you guys bicker through when you say,
of course,
God dammit.
Right?
When you forget the keys,
what's the of course is,
oh,
that is,
that is the,
that's the movie trailer.
That's not the movie of me getting angry.
I mean this,
it's Haaretz.
Yeah,
you just caressed I have like a string that's almost like Carlin's seven dirty
words.
Like I,
I can't,
I can't do it unless I'm mad.
I know Qantas in their cock sucker.
Yeah.
What about dog?
Couldn't fucking cock sucking mother fucking cunt.
Like I'll do that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I go,
I go mother fucking God.
Yeah.
A lot of fun.
God mother fucking damn it.
But there's something about pronouncing the whole world,
it takes the edge off motherfucking Goddamn Cock sucker.
Yeah.
It just,
it takes it away.
You know,
it's good for you.
Right?
There's studies about people who like run by angry scientists,
second sick or their wife's bitching at them.
No,
I got a lot of work to do on myself that I'm turning 50 this year,
so I'm already on the other side of it.
So maybe the last three hunting 50 so maybe the last three holes of the golf
course.
He's like off.
Wait,
do you play golf?
No.
Okay.
I just want to know.
All right.
Do you ever seen a shrink before a therapy?
I went to therapy.
But you stopped going.
Well after a while it's just like,
well,
you know,
I've told all the bad stories and I'm always gonna have problems.
It's just becoming like this,
you know,
lifelong car payment.
Now to have to come over here and be like,
well this happened.
My garage door was locked and it's just,
I just felt like a pussy after while like when are you going to just,
you know,
get off this fucking couch here and go live your life and stop having to talk to
this fucking person.
Yeah.
You're full of anger because you don't flog yourself for for being voce.
Would you stop it?
Like you have some sort of psychology degree,
10 years in therapy.
I've watched the football for 40 years.
I shouldn't be somebody coach.
I agree.
Yeah.
Then you're going to like super impose your fucking issues of the psychos in
your life onto me.
It's like fucking alcoholics.
They always like,
oh yeah,
you're drinking,
you're drinking.
You must be like me,
the whole world because they're addicts.
So they're so fucking self involved.
The whole world has to be like them.
Yes,
I agree.
I'm so glad you're here to put Christine and her place.
I'm the worst.
I know.
And you think you're a fucking shrink right now.
I mean,
let the guy,
we get eight sometimes me join.
I want to ask bill something.
Is this funny to you?
Jesus.
So this guys,
yeah.
What's going on?
Well,
he's backing into a mechanic.
It's
garage,
uh Oh.
Uh,
another part of the world.
So he's just kind of,
you know,
he's taking his time
kind of getting it aligned.
Jesus fucking
off.
It's funny cause y'all laughing
dude.
Somebody's got to teach set person a little throttle control.
Look how concerned he is.
He looked.
Yeah.
Life.
Life is cheap.
And that shop,
Huh?
Oh Man.
He just walked away.
Like I took it like a champ though,
Huh?
Yeah,
pretty much,
man.
No,
but funny,
I saw you laughing.
It's funny cause it shouldn't have happened.
It's unexpected.
You Die.
Yeah.
You know,
and it's so funny to think that that again,
part of the,
uh,
I think the guy in the red show be a little more concerned unless he was the guy
driving.
I think he was the guy driving.
Yeah.
Isn't,
isn't it a little funny
extreme.
You guys are both big.
Nobody,
if you listened to that,
you wouldn't think like just close your eyes and listen to that yelling.
You don't that doesn't that sound like I'm pinned.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
it
helps.
Yeah,
that's true.
See Cause Bill I enough already.
All right.
Yeah,
he's further than me.
Right.
But he thinks this is the funniest clip we've ever played.
I don't think it's the funny was really like it,
I think it shows a lack of empathy for others because I know that that man's
hurt.
I have a harder time laughing.
You know what I mean?
And I think that that's your husband's identity and that's his safety blankets.
So he stays in there cause he feel safe.
Who's therapizing knit?
I mean therapizing therapist is Abbas is isen what's my safe space?
Yeah.
What did I say that again,
Bill doing that.
So I bring a beat while that time.
He's crazy.
I like him.
Oh really?
I'm going to say mean things to him because he's crazy.
No,
I don't find it.
Oh know,
I
just grew up watching Benny Hill and the three stooges like I did just like,
uh,
you know,
physical slapstick.
Yeah.
It's,
it's reality TV slapstick.
How long have,
uh,
are you doing another,
you're doing another season of your show?
Yeah.
We're,
uh,
working on season three right now.
Is it awful to do that much work?
Uh,
it can be on days when it's,
it's not working days when it's not working.
I mean,
you can say that about any job,
but I mean,
I can tell you this,
it's way better than,
uh,
back when I had nothing to do and I was staring at my phone.
Yeah.
But there's definitely a days when it's,
it's not working.
It's like anything,
any job.
Some days it's great.
And you're loving it.
And then other times you're like,
oh my God,
how was it only 1130?
Did you love animated shows?
Like I just always wondered like,
no,
I just love being able to say what I want to say without a bunch of fucking
assholes tweeting about it.
And for some reason you could do that in an animation.
Oh right.
Oh,
that's why.
That's why I went into it.
Really?
Yeah.
I didn't know that.
Well,
cause I was telling all these stories on stage and it was like this,
this,
uh,
I feel bad for millennials.
Everybody shits on them.
It's not their fault.
It's the people who raised him and everything got like,
and that's all,
it's not even people raise some,
it's this social media shit that came out,
which is just a horrible,
for the most part experiment that's gone wrong.
And um,
everything just got labeled.
So all these stories that were funny and you could just,
Oh,
you know,
I had a dad like that,
or I had,
my brother was like that.
Or the guy down the street was like that.
Everything got labeled.
That's emotional abuse,
physical abuse,
bullying,
fat shaming,
ah,
you know,
all of it right down the thing.
So it's just this landmine of groans trying to just tell the fucking story and,
and um,
and then I get off stage and if said,
oh my God,
they would say my brother was like that and blah,
blah.
And I just got sick of,
I just stopped telling stories like that on stage.
And then I was walking my dog and I was thinking,
how the hell can I tell him?
And I don't know if I'd watched a cartoon or something,
I don't know if it's like one of I just animate him and I was just going to make
little animated shorts,
little shorts.
But like most Comedians,
I say,
I'm going to do it.
And then I never did it.
And then,
um,
I met Vince Vaughn and all those guys through Steve Byrne and uh,
uh,
my pilots never got picked up,
so I was like,
no,
I don't have a show idea.
Yeah,
they never get picked up.
And I'm not taking myself off the table for a year.
So if you guys have a movie or a TV and you want to cast me in something,
I will do that.
And then they go,
okay,
all right.
And I'm walking around us and I kind of felt bad.
I was like,
well,
you know,
all kind of have this idea for an animated show.
And they were looking to do one.
So they literally,
I was literally walking out the door and they go,
let's hear it.
I told it to him.
And then,
uh,
you know,
those guys are like amazing over there,
wild west.
And they got me in touch with the,
they brought him Mike Price from the Simpsons,
the Great Mike Price.
And together we cocreated the show it.
Here we are.
It's amazing,
man.
Yeah,
that's awesome.
Oh,
thank you.
And you could run for,
I mean,
animated shows fucking go forever,
man.
That's kind of the,
I guess the bag.
You can get little sick of it,
but it can be,
it all depends on that yet.
I will,
if I'm sick of it,
I won't do it anymore,
but I'm not sick of it.
I'm still having fun.
How many,
uh,
in a,
in a show like that,
cause it's funny too with Netflix,
you know,
you get into one show and you're like,
how many episodes are in the season?
It's like eight.
You're like,
God dammit.
And then the next show you pull up has 13.
And the next show,
I mean,
what is like a run is 10.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay,
that's cool.
Eight's not bad,
but if they're hour long things,
even if it's a good show,
it does kind of feel like all of a sudden you've dumped all this work in your
lap.
Like I got to sit down and watch all of these.
And then if the story starts to go a little in a way that you don't want it and
you're like,
ah,
fuck,
well things get,
I mean,
some of the show,
I'm going to finish this,
like a house of cards definitely got wacky as,
uh,
as the seasons progressed.
I never could,
I never got into that year.
Yeah.
It was really,
I didn't like the asides to the camera.
Oh yeah.
Like that's the senator and he's a Hooptie do.
But
I like,
I just fucking,
I I guess,
and they really going to do this every fucking 10 minutes.
That breaking of the fourth fucker wall.
I hate that shit.
I didn't like it in Ferris Bueller's day off.
Yeah.
Either do the fucking movie.
I'll make a documentary.
I don't like this hybrid shit.
Like I'm supposed to be excited and I'm like,
oh,
he's talking to me.
There's like,
I don't know their story.
I agree that that device can be distracting.
But the stories,
like the writing,
everything was,
I thought spot on.
So good season one,
season two got started off just like crazy by like three season four,
you're like,
what the,
yeah.
But it's hard.
It's hard to keep it going.
I saw this giant pizza dough and you just keep spinning and eventually,
you know,
there's no,
no show at some point.
Uh,
other than like the wire breaking bad.
There's a few that just somehow just stuck the landing the whole way.
But it's the hardest thing in the world to,
you know,
to keep going and not eventually,
path people going like,
you know,
oh my goodness.
It doesn't,
I don't like this character.
And then you've got to,
after a while,
years exhaust all your characters.
That's not worried about our show.
Cause people always fucking die on the show.
We're always introducing characters and then somebody gets killed.
So hopefully this season,
you know,
we're still working on it.
Nobody dies.
So that's awesome.
That's fantastic.
Um,
yeah,
I'm a big fan man,
so congratulations on all that for real.
Thank you.
I love you.
Even just the way he goes.
Yeah,
thank you.
You know,
whatever you just said,
you know,
congratulations,
blah blah blah.
This the lack of a mode.
Like I like how our relationship is him trying to do that and then sees me
looking at him like you're a psycho.
And then he laughs and he has like this infectious laughs and he just pulls me
back in.
Like most of my,
most of my brain is saying,
I got to get away from this guy because he's going to fucking hit me over the
head with a hammer.
But then that laugh,
I love his left.
Do you,
do people ever tell you,
especially after he was caught and the and the movies started to come out,
that you have a look of Whitey Bulger?
Is that a thing for you or no?
No.
Never.
I could totally see you planting little bit.
I'm not,
even if they shoot another one,
I think the role was down to me and Johnny Depp and they were like,
oh,
which way do we go?
I think the last thing I said to the casting director,
I was like,
but wait,
I'm already bald.
No,
we're still good.
I didn't go in for that.
You think I'm actually going up and you think he got offered that he's fucking
Johnny.
No,
but I figured,
you know,
they'd be like,
it's Bill Byrd.
Fucking,
let's take a look.
It's bilberry cells,
no movie tickets.
Right out.
She sold out an Improv,
a clip from bill show.
Oh,
is this here?
I Dunno.
Or producer sends us folders of Shit.
This is it.
What is this?
Black guys love the fuck and fuck good.
If you're a hot black guy and you want to fuck me at 2195 if you want to move
in,
you come move in,
but you got to fuck the I have any,
I need to be fucked a lot,
man.
You can rent free food,
free rent,
everything else,
man has a deal,
man.
Definitely your show.
No,
I'm just fascinated by that guy.
That's about as free as it gets.
He just doesn't care if his mother sees that.
He knows what he wants at a bone in his hair.
Free rent though.
Free Rent.
You get free food.
The reason why he's alone,
he suffocate shoe.
Yeah.
He's a very needy,
very needy to be fucked to be fucked alone.
It's like,
okay.
I was like,
you know,
if you were did that,
that he would be enjoyable for about two,
three days.
It would tire you out.
Yeah.
Then from jail,
homeless or you were thug.
Want to come?
We'll then frank would you too man?
Free Rent.
You can at least in the cake.
Fucking piss.
Somebody beat me up home.
I know.
You see me when I come up with today and try it out.
Try it out,
man.
Try it out when he thinks no,
I'm just trying to think of what happened.
He definitely was not built up as a child.
Now you,
that stuff beat me,
pee on me.
It's just like your parents are just,
I think there's this whole childhood were just yelling.
You're not good enough.
Yeah,
I was probably disappointing you.
I wish the kid across the street was my son and not use this horrible shit.
I feel bad for that guy.
I know.
But at the same time it's funny,
however.
Yeah,
but you know what's funny is like he's so hates himself that he just fucking,
he doesn't give a shit.
Yeah.
I mean,
how do you get like this?
No.
How does he have a jolly good?
What do you mean rent free?
Like what are you doing?
Does he drive like a ups truck and like they're going to see that and be like,
well,
you know what he does on his own time.
He's,
but here we can't give them any black and I partners though that'd be deliver in
the white neighborhoods,
so we keep that side of,
oh my God,
about drug use.
What do you think's going on?
Yeah,
I think he's a little high.
those rings around the eyes are pretty serious I think,
but that's such a crazy mustache that if he shaved that off,
I don't think I'd recognize him.
I didn't even really think about the mustache.
It's a good point.
Cheech Marin.
Yeah,
look and if he wants to track
my fucking pissed,
let me try it out.
She has applied only this.
Fuck man.
I'm looking for hardcore guys and meaning meaning I want him to live with,
I'm a hot swap.
My trash come down for fuck
true.
That's a good offer.
Free.
He's a hot cum dumpster.
Yeah,
it's got a lot going on.
Does he have enough pain in his life?
He's got to be on this show too.
You know what I mean?
That wasn't,
that wasn't like low hanging fruit.
That was actually,
if you did that in a movie,
if that was the character you would be nominated cause that that was an amazing
performance.
I actually,
uh,
what I would,
I was kind of addicted to was his cadence,
the way he had a very unique way of you want to [inaudible] it's some sort of,
somebody sent it says interesting speech pattern here.
This is like a,
he'll be always,
that might be the drug thing.
Like it's,
I've never been like a hard core drug guy,
so I don't know.
Uh,
we,
um,
what that is,
that's tweaking.
Is that what the kids say?
Twittering,
he's tweaking.
Well,
we play a lot of times interesting speech patterns.
Some people have lunch,
it comes off the math and the teachers just looks on his phone off.
Fuck,
I pause.
I was,
I videoing again,
just so you know,
his home address on this video and we had the decency to block that out,
but he gives his street address.
Yeah,
yeah.
If you want to try it on the Internet,
it's not a good thing.
The Internet is not a good thing,
but as much as we would all still be struggling if it wasn't the Internet,
uh,
you know,
it's good for comedians.
Internet has been great for Queens for the most part.
You can still get in trouble.
But like for people like that,
you know,
he just would have been muttering that around his house.
True.
Or maybe out in his front yard,
people walking by then he could deny it.
He could deny it.
I do that.
And then they just phone,
yes,
you did.
Back in the day was your word against theirs and you actually had to prove shit
and now there's like video evidence and now it's gone past that now.
Or if it's just somebody gives a really good detailed story,
people just go,
well,
I mean,
how could you make something like that up?
Yeah.
And uh,
that's become due process.
I feel like now too,
aren't we moving towards an age where like you remember,
you remember when the clippers owner got in trouble and he,
uh,
they recorded his conversation,
his mistress did and released it.
Don't you think we're,
I mean it might be past our life.
You don't think the police are going to tap into that.
Hey Siri,
how many fucking teeth does an alligator habitat was stupid fucking commercials.
They talk rolling all you,
you're recording your entire fucking personal life.
And what I'm saying,
you are going to be,
somebody is going to end.
Even if,
if
somebody hacks into that thing,
I'm saying that and they will,
they will fucking,
they will do their,
their cut of the film of your life and they'll make you look however the fuck
you want.
People are self duck.
It's dumb to have this fucking thing laying around.
It's going to happen sooner than we think where you are going to your Rick
conversations,
anything you said will be,
well,
someone will be able to pull that out at some point and be like,
this is what bill said.
You know what to think about the,
that all of that shit is,
is you have to like,
um,
this is a time to be fearless.
Yeah.
And I'm finding every body is like so many people agree on so many different
things right now that they had so afraid to talk about.
Cause you don't want to get in trouble.
You don't want to bring it onto you.
I don't want to get,
you know,
I don't want to say anything like it's just you,
you gotta like,
you know where the all black Tuxedo,
uh,
you know,
we're,
we're fighting for their freedom.
Like anything about foreign policy,
anything about all these sexual harassment cases there,
anything about any,
it's like there is this one line of fucking thought that you can have.
And if you don't have that a 100%,
if you go a little bit out of the turn and go,
well,
hey,
there's a little,
did you know this degree?
Any of that shit out the fucking window.
It's heightened care too.
It's heightened.
It's heightened in social media too because there's always been these nut bags
that will latch on to one thing you say.
But now they can congregate online and they can become an angry mob.
And now corporations listened to these idiot angry mobs.
And like what you're saying with the sexual harassment stuff,
it's bad enough just being accused of it and now everything gets taken from you
and there is no due process.
There is no like,
well,
hey,
there's no degrees as,
this guy's a rapist.
Hey,
this guy has said something.
Well,
Hey,
I had a bad date.
And then it's just all it's out out.
No out in the fucking woods to behind your ear over.
And then like some of this shit like,
I don't know,
like what is the end game?
It's like these people are they not allowed to ever earn a living again?
Are they supposed to become homeless?
I just you,
I dunno and,
but this is the thing,
obviously that behavior is completely unacceptable and you shouldn't be doing
it.
But the way that they're there,
I just looked at it this way,
it's like this shit was like a fucking pressure cooker because no one was
listening.
So in a way it's,
it's deserving on the male side that this is happening,
but it's fucking exploding now.
But any sort of like,
hey,
okay,
let's,
let's find out what happened.
Well,
you know,
there's,
there's none of that.
I've actually heard the argument that we shouldn't break down and explain the
degrees and the differences of these accusations.
Like,
I've heard that,
I think that's because there needs to be a corrective first,
right?
There needs to be a correction.
The pendulum,
like bill said,
was so far on this end,
and everybody's so fucking angry.
So now the pendulum's way here and now with the last thing,
with the z story,
I think people are starting to go,
well,
wait a minute.
Maybe there's gray areas to this discussion.
It's not just,
there's gray areas.
If you're looking at people who created law,
who are way smarter than me,
you know what I mean?
There,
there's,
there's misdemeanors and felonies,
murder one murder to manslaughter people that are in this thing with,
with their anger,
especially if they're emotional about it,
don't even want to entertain that conversation.
They are just like,
it's like you're trying to sell somebody like,
hey,
arm robbery and shoplifting or different,
right?
And they're saying,
no,
all the,
somebody took something that's the same,
take care of them in the public square.
I think you're being unreasonable because you're so emotional,
which is a totally fair thing to say.
But everybody else who's kind of thinking logically I think is open to the idea
that the majority of the people are.
Because anytime I've said that on stage,
like there's no like,
oh my God,
heckling shouting down.
There's no like fucking problems.
Eh,
same thing when you talk about the war.
There hasn't really been any problem,
but everybody is afraid to like,
you know,
it's,
it's not good to,
um,
you know,
when,
when it's,
it's this level of emotional reaction to,
to just just lay back and just be like,
just,
okay,
just don't get involved.
Don't get involved because it's going to,
you know,
God,
I mean,
you know,
the,
the thing about a sex thing is if you,
if you just get accused of it,
I've said for the longest time,
like if you get accused of rape,
they shouldn't show your face or name until you're convicted.
Because once somebody just gets accused as you have it,
you have to fucked done.
Not to mention,
even if you were just accused of it,
like everybody in your own like personal life,
your work it,
that's going to get out of course.
And now social media,
everyone's gonna rat you out in any ways and it's just like there's,
there's no comeback from that.
And if you're actually innocent,
and I've seen people going like,
well,
the incidences are that are really rare.
It's like,
I'll look them up.
Yeah.
There's enough of them that there should be some sort of thing like that,
but I just don't think you can keep anything under a lid anymore.
But,
um,
I really do believe that it's a time for like,
you know,
uh,
to not be afraid.
Um,
when you're on stage,
especially as a comedian,
like all,
like the,
they're just starting to like,
you know,
uh,
paint.
It's the weirdest thing.
Like when I was,
I was on stage,
I was joking with,
I was like this younger crowd.
And usually when he get to my age,
it's like getting 50.
It's like you kind of become like the corn ball,
like,
hey,
take my wife please.
You know,
like your style becomes old.
But they are so under a microscope,
they act like old people.
So like I,
I was watching,
I was at a show last night,
there was a couple guys like my age were like the edgy guys,
right?
Corn balls,
right.
Looking at the 20 something year olds in the crowd being like,
Jesus Christ,
these people are going to be running in the nation.
Oh my God.
Remember back in our day,
we just did Dick Jokes.
What are these?
I'm not really saying the Comedians,
I'm just saying the way the crowd.
Yes.
It's like you're on fucking doing a whole bunch of old people on a cruise ship.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's interesting.
We had dinner with someone that has three 25 year old children and he was saying
how these kids are so terrified now because of the whole,
uh,
you know,
me too.
Or the sexual harassment stuff there.
So under a microscope,
like you said,
that every move is like,
can I ask a graph?
I don't know what to do today,
like there.
So two less than it was at the laugh factory.
And W as I was walking out,
I was looking at my phone and there was a waitress in front of me and like I
just didn't see her and I bumped it up,
bumped into like her backside,
like her back all the way down.
I said,
Oh fuck,
I can sorry about that.
And she goes,
yeah,
that's cool.
I was like,
dude,
I've been on stage.
I've been doing this bit about the degrees of the sexual harassment,
things like how they're basically,
it's a bit about that.
Uh,
I did it in Phoenix,
Honolulu.
I did it at the store.
We get it.
You're work in the road.
People like you and I did it.
I did it at a fundraiser show here.
Oof Man.
Well,
when eggs,
well anytime you do a fundraiser,
people are in this phony,
uh,
sort of,
I have to pretend I care.
Yeah.
So it,
it,
and it goes beyond you,
obviously care cause you there.
Yeah.
But there is the cause,
but then it,
it seeps into everything else.
Yeah.
You know,
and then it becomes like,
oh,
you just,
but I usually one line [inaudible] usually like gets rid of it or whatever.
You know what I mean?
If you just call him on it,
then they can kind of like relax.
But yeah,
no,
I show,
oh it was,
it went pretty,
it went south pretty,
pretty badly.
You aren't able to recover.
I was able to recover after more than a moment and there was a little bit of
chaos in the room.
That's how,
that's not,
it was,
it was a totally,
you liked that.
It was like fuel.
It was fun.
Yeah.
So I mean if you're steering into it,
but I'm saying I hadn't experienced that reaction doing that bit.
In other words,
my experience,
sometimes you have bids where you're like,
I know this is going to run into like a,
a huge pushback.
This wasn't that bit to me because I had done it.
That was my,
like I had done it in places and it was always like a bit that worked.
And then this was the first time where I was,
well that's always funny.
We were like,
ah,
this one's going to get,
yeah,
it's going to be one of these shows.
Have Y'all,
cause you've done,
like obviously everyone know you've done a ton of specials.
Do you have in your catalog a bit that you're like,
that's the one that infuriated people the most,
in other words,
from your spouse?
The most reaction yet?
I gotta be honest.
I don't read any of that shit.
None of it.
I am,
I mean I'm,
I've,
I've read it,
but it's,
it's just,
it's silly.
Silly if you want to get,
like,
if you're like one stood out,
that's the look.
I know that I don't meet it anything in a malicious way.
Right?
MMM.
So somebody on the Internet,
why are,
or whatever,
they watch it,
they have the right to take it.
Like I said it seriously.
I mean,
if you want to do that,
yeah.
But just because you think that I meant it seriously doesn't mean I now meant it
seriously.
Right.
You don't control the fucking universe in.
Yeah.
I like when they argue with you,
like,
no,
I was just joking.
No,
yeah,
I can tell you blah,
blah,
blah.
So it's like,
okay,
so you know what my intent and my thoughts are more than I do.
Yeah.
That's what your argument is right now.
I guess.
So just saying I'm a liar.
I don't know,
but it's just like,
it goes nowhere.
Yeah.
And you make their day if you write back and forth.
And uh,
fortunately I've always been at this level in the business where like,
I don't,
I don't get like,
uh,
too many of those types of things,
but I also think that
the stuff that I say isn't that crazy.
Like I don't,
I don't,
I'm not really super dark.
I'm not,
uh,
you know,
I'm just sort of,
I always said just the loud guy at the bar who's just,
you know,
you think he's making sense and then you find out he flunked everything in
school and you're like,
oh,
this guy's just an idiot.
That is a great description of you.
Yeah.
I don't mean the idiot part.
I mean the loud guy at the bar that you want,
every everything
where you bad in school.
Oh yeah,
I did.
I did really well in elementary school and then I did pretty good in junior
high.
And then when it mattered like high school to what they looked at,
that's when the kind of the wheels fell off.
But uh,
you know,
my favorite thing is about,
um,
like when I hang out with comics,
what I want to know the most.
I would love a 15 minute documentary on every comics,
like a house,
like where they grew up.
Like I would love to see like a short doc Netflix doing that on your 15 minutes,
they're just going to whittle the special down to absolutely nothing.
Comedians,
houses.
When you love though to see like bill's folks,
siblings like that would be the best.
I want to hear every,
I want to hear the therapy version.
I want to watch mom and dad fight.
I want to watch you want to spray.
It's just intriguing.
Creeps me out.
Really.
I don't like this.
I,
uh,
like I felt like what that is story.
Like I started to read,
it's just like,
dude,
I don't want to know about his private.
This is not,
I don't want to slide of my fucking business,
but just you doing that,
just you doing that,
you don't,
you all you heard was one side of the story and it's just,
that's not how court works.
Oh,
I totally agree.
If he just heard one side,
every fucking thing would be a conviction.
It would be compelling.
Yeah.
Everything would be compelling and we're totally fucking make sense.
It's when you hear the other person's side,
that's where the artist and then trying to sift through and look at somebody.
Yeah.
And looking at how somebody like emotion,
cause I ran into somebody and uh,
they were talking about how they had some of that bullshit going on and they
were like,
well,
you know,
I mean that's just how it is and blah,
blah,
blah.
And it was very like laid back about it.
And I was just thinking I would be fucking livid.
Yeah.
So I was thinking like that,
that's not a,
so I don't know what happened,
but if I was in the jury,
I'd be like,
that's not the fucking reaction.
Even though he's saying I'm innocent,
I'm innocent,
I'm going to just sort of listening,
going like,
you know,
you,
you sound like you're in a fucking yoga class.
And he's like,
Yup,
that's how it goes.
So,
you know,
but I mean that's the time we're living in and I,
kind of fucking,
yeah.
And it's just like,
okay,
that's not how I would've fucking dealt with it.
I think about Louis Ck and I love him so much and I,
I want like,
I feel like he should just be punished.
Like we should just shame him a little bit,
but not take away everything.
Right.
Well doesn't that feel fair?
Like,
all right,
we'll shame him a bit.
I think that get them to knock it off.
I think that what's actually going to happen is a version of what you're saying.
Cause the shaming has happened,
punishment has happened and then it's just time.
So at a certain time,
it's not like,
dude,
there's so many people that want to see him and see what he has to say and just
our special ever like in five years,
I don't know how long,
but it'll definitely happen without a doubt.
Without a doubt.
Unless he's like,
I'm fucking done with all of this.
So I moved to France.
They would definitely welcome it.
They always,
yeah,
the French are checked off.
Everybody just calls.
Yeah they don't,
they think that what's happening now is ridiculous and American women,
Catherine what dyno and Brigitte Bardot or like decent malicon mentally this is
how they fled.
They're totally,
me too is these nonsense.
There's so indoctrine there are women that are,
it,
it probably somewhere in the middle like the French get too much respect for
like,
oh they can have mr citizens.
It's sort of acceptable.
Do you go over over there like a,
you know like in Paris or whatever,
that there,
there was a misery to that place.
So,
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I don't think that there is like a,
cause I used to look at that and I used to be like,
okay,
are they just like honest or they just like,
uh,
in the future or if they take like a wrong turn at a,
I think it's a little bit of both.
Yeah.
They are in the future and they also took a wrong turn.
And I just think it all depends on how you're wired to like plug it in.
So,
um,
I dunno,
those are my new points of view,
by the way.
Why?
Just make sure that I say like,
this is what I think,
but I don't fucking know.
No,
because I'm so sick of people talking about,
yeah.
Absolutes.
I unfollowed a lot of people too on like Twitter.
Like when the people who go into Lenny Bruce mode and all they can do is just
tweet about Trump.
It'd be like,
so this happened and then they put the thing on there and it's just like,
I just,
and every fucking day,
every fucking second.
And it's just like,
okay,
and what's the solution?
Right.
I don't have any,
I'm just going to show you all this negative shit from this point of view that's
going to have you like,
it's like,
it's depressing.
It is.
It is depressing.
Yeah.
You got like a,
I used to,
I was,
I was in,
uh,
like indulging in news fucking 24,
seven from the like election day through the written in like months and months.
A month at a certain point.
I think another like Steve Martin Comedian,
right?
It's right.
Right now for another just Steve Martin.
Just silly,
silly,
yeah.
Facility.
But there was a brilliant behind what he was doing like that.
I don't just mean like silly,
stupid,
silly,
brilliant.
Totally brilliant.
This is a good moment for that cause you're going fucking heavy and um,
I don't know.
And I love silly.
So I'm looking for,
because I know it's not me,
so I'm looking forward to whoever the fuck it's going to be.
Now you have a child.
Are you raising your child?
Not at all gender Pronoun.
None at all.
Okay.
So I gender,
gender,
just throw food into a room in the general direction.
Are you raising your child by the gender binary or your car or is it,
this is why I would never do that to my kid.
May well,
I get into something,
right.
I always get into shit and then a year later I don't give a fuck about it.
This kid has like a developing brain.
I'm going to dump like my,
uh,
whatever Mike fucking my own constitution has shit on it.
I just feel like that is like adult stuff and you should allow kids to be kids.
Can they,
can they have a fucking child?
Because right now what I love about when I grew up was I was allowed to be a
kid.
Yeah.
And like,
you know,
I didn't like this,
like the stuff that these fucking kids could,
they could see any up beheadings card core or all of this shit to do.
They could have access to.
So,
um,
I would never have sex,
some sort of political agenda as to way.
Um,
but are you going to force your child to be recognized as FEMA girl,
are you going to say like,
you get to choose your gender later?
What do you mean force my kid?
If you recollect kids,
a girl,
no sad,
so yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Subjective now and know that you're actually,
it's kind of a form of child abuse if you make the gender just because their
sexual organs are female.
I don't agree with that and good luck to how you want to raise your kid and I'm
going to raise my kid the way I want to.
Okay.
All right.
Amy,
I feel like you're just,
Sweden is based food thinking country in the world when it comes to questioning
gender,
the gender neutral Pronoun Hen is now commonly used by most Swedes.
This is Nikos Room on how this Nico,
Nico is two and a half.
I'm Mayfair is a almost five and a half
to being called a woman or a man or a boy or a girl is.
It's shameful.
It's what the idea is that you are going to force your child to be too gender
identify as female even though just because of her sexual organs or daughter is
a girl.
I mean,
and if she wants to work on carburetors or yeah,
do some quote Guy Shit,
I don't give a fuck.
Yeah,
I know,
but it's this leg that way into labor,
her girl.
So then what will cause then once you have two kids,
if you have a boy and a girl,
you always have to say their names then.
Yeah.
Just over and over and over again.
Well,
gender and you can't just go hand came in here and pissed on the floor.
Which hand?
What's wrong with that?
You got,
you got us like colors.
I hope we're not forcing her to wear pink.
I would just not hurt you.
I would appreciate if you stop seeing her.
I'm sorry.
Is that the head they can,
yeah.
I mean,
here's the thing.
There's this big mystery.
People don't realize that sexual organs don't dictate your gender.
That's just a sexual Oregon.
That's the point.
Bill.
I don't know if you can wrap your fucking head around that idea.
You know,
I must be a caveman.
I,
yeah,
you can do whatever you want to do.
As long as you're not hurting people.
I don't,
I don't have a fucking problem with that.
I would be just would like you to open your mind to maybe letting your child
decide what giant my mind I listened to you.
I don't agree with what you're saying and it's my kid and I'll raise her the way
her,
the way I want to grow.
There it goes again.
I have knee as number we'll call hostile pronouns.
Okay.
Family,
the sex you were born with does not dictate your gender identity.
Yeah.
Oh,
very sad.
Okay.
I absolutely 100% agree with that.
But I don't think a pronoun dictates no,
and I don't mean to be like all male by saying Dick cisgender white privilege,
um,
which you are right in their heterosexual,
you will write it in there.
I the white women's saying white privilege to me,
it's just because their lives are slightly less awesome than mine is so fucking
annoying.
Oh,
I used to do a bit about that.
Although all the white women crying when Hillary Clinton lost like their lives
are going to be that affected,
like they still going to be drinking their glass of Rosie at four in the
afternoon,
free pin up to three 58 two.
I have a problem.
Um,
yeah,
I gotta be honest with you.
Like I,
since becoming a parent,
I'm still a rookie,
obviously only a year end.
There's a lot of shit that other parents say to me or stuff that they're doing
that I observe it and I just fucking,
I just fade back because,
because I,
I,
I understand how much they love their kid so they,
and I'm not going to go in and fuck with whatever it is that they're doing,
which is why it's so crazy that these people who've decided to do this,
not that,
that they've decided to do this hand thing is that they're now going to fucking
attack people who don't.
Right.
Which is where all that,
you're not liberal anymore.
Right.
You are a fascist,
fascist.
Liberal.
Yes.
That's what you are was you're dictating.
But this is the thing though.
They are a very small portion of the population who knows where,
where the pressure points are and they go after advertising money and then
everybody caves in and everybody has to live off of money.
So everybody gets afraid like,
oh fuck,
if I don't start saying hand and if I don't start saying this,
then I'm gonna lose my job.
I can't.
We're going to become homeless,
we're going to live in our cars or it's going to be cars.
I just said this privilege in our car and these minority,
the very small group of people,
like you said,
these far,
far,
far less paper tiger and everybody's folding.
Yeah.
It's really interesting how they got to dictate the norms now like these,
these outliers of society,
because people are choosing self preservation for logic.
Chicken shits over yet and the sky is falling and it's a fucking acorn on your
head.
And I'm not saying that,
that all that hence shit is bullshit.
It's,
it's like they're there.
What they're trying to do is a good thing.
Their heart is in the right place,
but to then become like this fucking fist that is just beating on people
everyone else has to do.
And that's a,
you know,
if I'm cool with you doing it and I'm doing it my way and I'm not forcing you to
do it my way,
then like why can't you give me that same common courtesy as an adult?
I guess they feel oppressed too because I guess they feel like,
well I've been having to do it your way for all this time.
We should all do it my way now or something.
I don't know.
I'm just trying to think of,
I guess,
but it's like I didn't come up with the way and I never told you to do it your
way,
but then it's also like that would just be like,
uh,
you know,
somebody murdered my family,
said I'm going to go out and start murdering other people's families.
Right.
That'd be fine.
And then I'd be like a,
then I'm right.
How is use key for them?
Sometimes it's mixed and it depends,
you know,
because in Sweden we have hen the gender neutral pronoun in Swedish.
I think Mika has always said when I've asked,
it's been she or Ken.
So the other thing is you could also do changing pronouns if you wanted to do
that with your child.
Like have led to it.
I don't think I've ever given a shit less about a topic.
If this is what people want to do,
go ahead,
go ahead and do it.
But you know,
there's like certain things like you just,
you know,
certain things,
you come in,
you're like,
hey,
you know,
let's,
I'd like,
there's all this stuff in education that blows my mind that people are talking
about that I,
I,
but I am open to everything.
Look,
this is the thing to it.
If people across the street use Hana,
whatever the fuck they're going to say this county,
and that's what they want me to do,
I'll do it when I'm addressing their kids.
But when I'm in my house,
I'm going to do what I want to do.
If you don't mind.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I do have a problem with that,
that I,
you'd be sorry.
Yeah.
Fuck off.
You want to come over for a barbecue?
Yeah.
One thing we may heads,
would you have a barbecue with the hens if they weren't cons.
Yeah.
If they weren't constantly dumping their fucking agenda.
And then also like secretly trying to put their agenda and to my kid,
like,
like a fucking lunatic flipping a burger and then they'd be talking to that
single parents are fucking psychos.
They do that.
Like,
like if you like raising your kid is like a vegetarian and shit.
Like people who eat meat like they want,
they want like people,
just the thing about humans,
the big flaw that we got is that a lot of times we,
we wanna we wanna win more than finding out what's right.
Right.
You just want to win.
Totally.
So,
uh,
it can cause you to do shit like that.
And uh,
you know,
and I bet I've been guilty of it.
Oh,
that's a hand from fucking Sweden.
Do you feel like you want to be right a lot?
No.
I want to win.
You want to when I'm saying no,
I would love to find out what all the right answers are.
But you want to win.
But uh,
yeah,
I find like when I'll be arguing with my wife that I want to win,
but I,
over the years as I've matured,
I want to win for less time.
Right.
If I know I'm wrong,
right.
A bad guy.
Right.
You know what your eye,
your eye,
I've found,
I should've said Cock sucker motherfucking car.
I shouldn't have said that.
I found the garage door that the being right thing for me is the urge was
strongest always with my mom and that as I've gotten older,
become a parent and just realize how,
how much energy it takes that I constantly throw in the towel before it starts.
Just I don't even,
I don't care about winning,
I just,
it's like self preservation.
That is a,
that is a high level of existing that I'm trying to get to.
What I just like this.
Uh,
I did real well over the last couple of years.
Especially like,
you know,
holidays are like big get togethers where it,
when people start fucking doing that.
Oh my God,
Hillary Clinton.
Oh my God.
Trump on there by the left.
The right fucking transgender people.
Whatever topic they're talking about.
Sure.
And somebody is just going on like a rent and if they say something that I don't
necessarily agree with,
I used to,
I would have just fucking go right.
Like a mosh pit.
I would go right in the middle of it.
Now what I do is,
my default thing now is to myself,
I just go,
oh boy.
Yeah that's it.
And then I leave and I'm trying to go back to the old school rules and used to
be you didn't talk politics or religion at a social thing?
It was considered rude.
Yeah.
Cause it's going to cause fights and it was like one of those.
And you,
I've never
ever had a political or religious argument with someone who didn't agree with
me.
We're in the end,
we've been like,
you know what?
Now I think the way you think.
Of course all you do is blow out your voice.
Screaming yellow feel.
Yeah,
yeah.
You'd just,
And then you're terrible.
Then you're a bad mood.
You're going to get your car,
you're going to drive like an asshole.
Yeah.
And it's just,
uh,
you just got,
I save it for the stage now.
I'd just be like,
hey,
this person said this.
I'll say my point to a crowd,
you know?
And then maybe I'll get heckled,
like,
that'll be like the worst argument I'll get in,
but I just,
um,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't have any answers to it and I,
and I don't want to argue with people anymore,
so I can't just,
I just cannot.
Oh,
right,
okay.
I just do it to avoid the feeling of how upset I'll know I'll get,
oh boy.
Yep.
Yeah,
definitely my own,
oh boy.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Good point.
I actually go like,
I see what you're saying.
Even when it's like totally opposite,
I'll be like,
yeah,
I know what you mean.
I see what you mean is I don't want to fight with them.
I don't want to argue.
Yeah.
But people like,
it's funny,
like they tried to like put their like agenda in deck.
You'd just be hanging out with your kids and stuff.
Yeah.
Isn't she cute with that little toy phone that she has?
You know,
I'll tell you what,
if Trump passes this bill,
but blah,
blah blah.
Oh boy.
Oh right.
There we go.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Are you,
um,
are you road dog in it right now or no?
Um,
I took January off cause it was my daughter's birthday and I just wanted the
whole month like assault and number nine.
Yeah.
Are At Lambeau?
Uh,
no I did.
I made her a cake though.
That's nice.
So that's my tradition.
Die Every year.
I'm going to make her a cake.
So,
uh,
hopefully that'll make up for,
you know,
my outburst or whatever,
which I'm really going to try not to do.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
I got a lot of work to do that,
so she won't eventually hate me someday.
Do you think about that?
I think about it all the time.
All the time.
No,
because I am a very hateful person.
If you live with me,
I have my good qualities or whatever.
It's weird,
man.
If I could just stay in the energy that I am right now.
Yeah.
If I could just stay in this during times of heightened emotion.
Uh,
it's really my goal because I think if I learned how to do that,
I would,
I'm doing everything else fine.
Yeah.
And if I could just,
but that thing is so bad,
it's like water damage.
It leaks into all areas of my life.
I could just get that under control.
That energy.
Yeah.
It's like what could she bitch about?
Right,
right.
I saw you.
I got a job.
I'm bringing in good money.
We'll live in a great life.
Right.
You don't really have any wants.
Yeah.
With,
you know,
I cook,
I like doing dishes.
Jesus,
you know,
you're not a fucking maniac.
I'm a maniac,
dude.
I,
I just,
I wake up,
I,
my motors running and I get shit done.
You know,
we were at that part,
but yeah,
I snap like,
you know,
too much.
Is it,
is it really often the snapping?
Uh,
it's,
you know,
I want to say it's gotten better,
but,
uh,
she doesn't see my champion really know.
You know,
I,
I got to work on,
I remember,
uh,
we know we ran into each other at that party a few weeks ago.
Remember that?
No recollection.
Yes.
Okay.
Um,
that was one of the things I left was like,
man,
you seem like you're in a really good mood.
That's what was my,
that was my thought about it.
Like,
you were like,
just like you just found out,
I dunno that they fucking sold the house or some shit.
You know,
like,
you were just like,
you had such a happy demeanor.
I was like,
Geez.
Yeah,
it wasn't a good,
well,
that's good.
I don't get that review that often,
so that's good.
I might even have to tell my wife that.
I think you should know that party we went to,
Tom Segura said that I had a really,
really nice energy.
You know I played drums with somebody the other day and they,
and she was on bass and she said,
you got,
you got a good energy.
This is shit that I've never heard.
I was like,
wow.
Yeah.
That's what I took away from that part.
It's like bill's and are really good.
I think he's way,
you seem much happier than the first time you did the show.
I'd say.
I mean
you seem a lot happier than you were.
It's like,
I don't want to bring you back to that.
What?
That actually breaks my heart.
Like the egg shells that you just said that,
cause I don't want to be that guy.
Never wanted to be that guy.
And I became that.
I became that guy.
Cause you,
you just a little more introverted I think in a little more maybe distrustful.
It felt,
oh back then I'll have solution.
Had the guard up.
Yeah,
the gardener.
Where's it coming from?
Me?
Like I'm fucking bill burr.
I was like the black dude.
And predators shaving my head,
I can see it over there.
And then trees.
I was a paranoid lunatic.
Yeah.
So what do you think hat like less than that over the light got out of
conspiracy theory.
I stopped doing that because it was just becoming insane and it was becoming
that guy that you didn't want to talk to and uh,
I stopped watching the news because I just realized it's just like I can't solve
any of these problems and knowing that they exist makes me sad.
So I just watch sports and you know,
hang out with my kid and thing.
I'm all about the movement but I,
I'm not the leader of the movement.
Right.
Okay.
If somebody wants to fucking figure out how to clean up all that trash and the
Pacific Ocean,
I'm all about it.
I don't know how to do it,
but I'm not going to watch a documentary looking at it and seeing my,
all my toothbrushes for my entire life still floating out there cause they made
out of plastic.
Like,
I need a new toothbrush right now and I can't get myself to fucking buy one
cause I'm like,
this thing is going to be in the ocean 200 years after I'm dead.
Broken down into like little particles that a porpoise is going to breathe into
because God forbid,
you know,
I got a cavity so I'm fucking with this thing in the middle that lives thousands
of miles,
not even in the same like world is me.
Can I send you a quip?
I Dunno.
What equip is this?
A new toothbrush?
Oh,
you know what you look,
you're looking at or write a prescription.
I feel like this is the end of a therapy session.
I'm going to send you a quick,
okay.
Just let me see.
What is it quip?
It's a tooth to tooth brush.
Is it a good one?
Yeah,
it's really good.
It's a fancy really fancy one.
Please.
It's on me.
You can fucking throw or you just try it out.
Is this how you handle your relationships and people were,
I was just should have bitched about something bigger.
Yeah.
Fucking hate my car.
So that,
you know,
you get your car
now you've been with your lovely wife for how long?
How long have you guys been together?
Uh,
I don't know.
Like 1415 years.
Yeah.
It's a good run.
I love him more than ever.
I've get,
see she's the best fucking happy rest.
Nice.
I know.
It's refreshing.
I hate when people hate their spouses.
You can always,
I bitch about her on stage but I love it.
No,
but you meant it.
I fucking saw that bit and you meant it.
All right.
Don't yell at me.
So you got to put my head through the dresser because I love you.
You
know,
you're always looking for ways to spice it up.
Every relationship is,
I wouldn't want to bring that to me.
I'm wondering if that's what you're looking to do.
Don't say that I you will consider something different.
Hi Melanie.
I'm Scottio with ecstatic hearts.
Tantra.
I was just wanting to share that there are many ways to orgasm.
You don't actually have to be having sex orgasm just from hugging.
Ah,
ah,
ah.
You know what's funny is they like if you switch their hair,
they can be each other.
They each other,
the whole body can be orgasmic and especially when you start off awesome boss
law,
why they stopped everything can be a trigger for her.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
That would you and your wife go to a con hugging seminar if we send you that?
Because that would,
it would just interfere with all the things I'm trying to succeed with.
Like if I could just,
you know,
a water bottle,
you just touch it with your fingertips will bring you to orgasm.
I would never be able.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Good for them that they've found that doing they're full of shit though.
Well I think it'd be weird when they have a baby and that was in the rails,
how soft it is and it just,
then now there are two open when they become like,
oh my God,
it's relative against the baby.
Yeah.
I just loving it a different way than you did you do with your,
if your wife came home and was like,
we need to start getting into tantric staff.
I'm,
I booked a seminar I want,
I really want to be open to that.
And I would say,
no,
I'm not going.
Do you want to read up on it?
Once you go to like a,
uh,
public sex thing with other couples,
it's just you like the,
the fortress you've left the gate open and some Weirdo that's is going to come
fuck.
And I should judge some fucking person that's in the shit that I'm not into is
going to get in there.
And uh,
you know,
and there's just,
yeah.
Even think they're going to infiltrate your wife and your relationship.
Yeah.
I just think you're just bringing up something that's,
yeah.
You open up Pandora's box.
That's why upon intent,
that's a wise no.
What if she were to get into other things?
Exploring her femininity.
Um,
well this,
so a clip we could show him about the woman who was exploring her femininity.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You guys don't have to do the long set up.
See if we can just watch funny clips if you want to.
No,
no,
it's just we wanted to see,
um,
all right.
Oh,
how I felt about it.
Yeah.
Um,
or if your wife were to suddenly do something like this.
Yeah.
You have great glasses by the way.
Thanks.
I just got them.
My vision is getting terrible.
Bad to do.
You look good in those.
I,
I've,
I've tried on glasses.
It's not a good thing.
No.
The first thing I thought of those real effective force.
Next Steps.
Second thought.
What?
I actually,
the first I was like is that the woman from the bangles that I had the crush.
Oh isn't once we know what she's doing right there though.
This woman,
she's coming with finger paint.
Okay.
Yeah.
And I just wanted to share with all of you why don't need to,
yeah.
Shami.
Placing menstrual blood all over my face and what power it holds for us as women
to fully [inaudible] this part of self that we've been shaming because so many
lifetimes.
Yes.
The overcorrection.
Yeah.
He's that show a graph.
The videos.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But you're going to wait now.
She'll get away with it cause she's beautiful now.
What kind of reaction do you think she would've gotten?
If she did black guys who want to fuck and fuck it for free rent that's put out
that video,
we wouldn't know.
We wouldn't have seen it because there's so many.
There's so much of that.
Like that guy was just in a,
he flipped the script.
Yeah,
he does.
he did.
Yeah.
He might have actually been re reading from somebody else.
That might have been plagiarism,
but
that's like,
we know that that we used to be a brilliant fit.
Announce a hacky thing when somebody like croons like psycho lyrics to a song.
[inaudible] switching it up.
You're not sure that that's basically what that guy was doing sex way.
It's interesting you brought her looks because what we were saying a few
episodes ago,
if this were not an attractive woman,
there'd be a whole different reaction.
I mean the fact that she might've created a new genre of porn period on the
blood.
On her face.
Yeah.
Like if that woman was at the hugging seminar,
I might've been more open to it and I'm really sick of like people.
Like that's another thing like regular looking people all the way to ugly people
trying to convince us that that our,
our standards of beauty where somehow it's like,
no,
it's fucking beautiful and they should be naked and we shouldn't be most
upsetting with children when there's ugly children and people keep saying that
like,
you're beautiful.
It upsets me so much.
You know,
I'm thinking more of adults.
I'm thinking of this movement where they,
okay,
yeah.
Oh boy.
I'm talking about where they're like the,
the morbidly obese a runway modeling and you're like,
what were beautiful?
And you're like,
hmm.
I don't think,
no.
I think if you're going to be in a movie,
you should be,
if you're going to get naked on film and TV and movie,
you should be in the best fucking shaking.
Could possibly.
Yeah.
Or you go the other way for the laugh,
right.
What you're doing it for the laugh,
but like to,
to sit there and just show off an unworked out body and say that that's brave.
It's like the bravery is the person who has to look at it.
Yeah.
Because listen,
we all look at each other's fucking regular bodies.
You know it when you're in a relationship because you love the other person,
right?
You have to love somebody.
Right.
You know what I mean?
That's what's amazing about beautiful people is you're not in love with them,
but you can see him naked.
That's how that's,
that's,
that's really in shape,
right?
I mean I know the whole idea.
It's like no one wants to see me naked.
I joke,
you know what it looked like nick and I looked like I have the exact same
bodies,
the pink panther,
which is just a big head and it's just straight down no ass.
And then I have like as a pink panther,
it was like in first trimester like Emma,
there was,
but we live in an age though that if I was completely naked I would be called
brave.
Courageous rather than fucking rude and inconsiderate to make you guys look at
me.
Oh yeah.
I mean I've been asked to,
I mean be a shirtless.
I'm like,
it's disgusting.
Like is it for,
cause it's funny cause if it's going to be funny,
that's one thing.
But like if if like it can I act like I think I'm good looking right?
Right.
Then I would do it.
But if I'm going to do it like Yemen,
this is my body deal with it and literally put the pressure on you to not laugh
at me and ridicule me is I am living in such a world of fucking delusion.
I don't have any fucking pigment just for me.
No matter what shape I got into to take my shirt off,
I would be blinding people.
Right?
Yeah.
I have,
I have other things that I'm good at,
right?
I can vote.
I can think that's it.
Make,
uh,
I get errands done really good at that.
I don't mind doing dishes.
He likes doing dishes.
Come to ours.
We hate it because beauty is a commodity.
You know,
models,
these chicks,
everyone makes fun of,
they might,
who knows if they're intelligent or not,
but that's a special thing.
If you're board member in the 70s if you are born and you had nice teeth and
real big tits,
not fakers is before cosmo hernia surgery,
that was a really big deal.
Like we're Calwell the Hov Lane.
Yeah.
That was special.
Uh,
you know,
now you can go to the surgeon and have whatever,
correct it,
but back then beauty was a real,
I know it's a gift.
I hate the lie of beauty.
So much like the idea that we're going to act like these really beautiful people
are,
you know,
not special.
They are.
That's your special thing.
Yeah.
I get in a debate with my wife because she goes,
if people want to do that,
it makes them feel better about themselves.
It's fine.
Which is a very enlightened
point of view.
I look at it is you quit,
you gave in.
It's weak.
What,
what plastic surgery.
Well,
that's an extreme,
stupid opinion,
but it's what I just like.
Well,
I'm,
I'm of the belief is,
especially in this business to age,
naturally,
you're going to look way better.
Yeah,
I agree.
Because trying to be 50 and looking like you're 25,
you're just going to look weird.
Yeah.
It never looks at 25 and you'll,
but you kept yourself in shape and you look 43 that's about is the best that you
can hope for.
But as you get older,
uh,
you know,
and it's,
it's like you're going to,
you,
you start to look fucking nuts,
but you can play like a,
a character or something like that.
I love these people who are still like in you,
if you're 50,
you're going to be the next Brad Pitt.
It's like a would've happened by now.
Right?
Just stop trying to be good looking and just be a fucking regular guy that beat
you.
Gotta get on that thing.
So like literally what they're doing with looks would be like if somebody who
sucks at math should now like design a plane and get into fucking aviation's,
everybody else has to crash and die because this person feels bad that they're
not good at math.
Like you gotta be like,
like part of being successful is,
is not only figuring out what you're good at,
but figuring out what you suck at so you don't waste time.
And I have not wasted one day of my life trying to become a male model.
How much,
like what a fucking treadmill that would be to be on it.
I would be exactly where I was when I started.
He started now bill burr,
the hot model be great.
If I did that,
it would just be,
it would if I was serious that we just be unintentional comedy and then I would
make it out of ridicule.
But like that's true.
That's true.
You know,
like I look at somebody like Pamela Anderson who were at our heyday,
you were like,
wow,
she will define the 90s right.
And then,
you know,
as we all do,
we all get older and,
and to try to maintain the persona you had 20 years ago,
30 years ago.
But that's the regular book.
Terrible.
Like myself.
If you actually resent good looking people,
which I don't,
I love him.
I love looking at it.
The fucking,
I did a movie one time,
I would say,
who was this person was so beautiful.
Like I never had this thought before.
I was like sh her forearms were beautiful.
Yeah,
like that's like the level of genetics.
It's just like you would just like sculpted,
you know?
Um,
I can't remember my point cause I just started thinking of her forearms,
Pamela and being,
the thing is,
is the,
all of those people that,
I guess these people have issues with that.
Oh my God,
she's so beautiful ended and they don't have to fucking work for anything.
The thing about it is,
is this the expiration date?
Those people never age well because everybody's looking like I love when they,
people go,
oh my God,
did you see so and so?
What the fuck happened to her?
You just see songs.
What happened?
He's like,
dude,
what happened to you?
What happened?
It's like they're coming down to your fucking level and you weren't good looking
to begin with.
And you're 20 years old or do you think you look better?
They need like everybody,
what happened to everybody?
That's right.
Everybody looks older.
So,
but what you're saying is true,
cause we talk about that on this show that the cosmetic surgery thing.
Yeah,
he just looks solid and the truth is,
I mean even though it,
you can give it both sides.
I've seen it more now.
You know,
and traveling and stuff is like guys that do it,
these men that the pullback back,
their foreheads don't move.
They have a bad wig and then they,
they're older and they have just blinding white teeth cause they got the
pictures of like make them make them super white.
Oh yeah.
It looks like
it looks like a spotlight from a stadium.
RVC Yeah.
Yeah.
Like,
like led lights on the front of a jeep and they know like I look dumb and you're
like,
you look out of your yeah.
And you know what they look like too.
After awhile they start looking like raceless.
Like it's like that's not a white dude anymore.
That's not Asian.
I don't know.
Yeah.
It's like are you an alien?
Do you just fucking land air and you don't know what it is true.
What's going on with the fake Tanner?
The lit up?
Yeah.
It just like,
and then this is something that you do with your eyes.
You just,
you become like a,
uh,
like,
I don't know what it is.
It's almost like animation.
You don't like the Simpsons look like they like,
they're like,
like live action animated people.
It's an,
it stands out more maybe because it's newer for men,
but like when it's men,
I just,
I'm more feminine.
You look worse.
You Do,
you look more feminine.
We do.
You know what?
I noticed that when I did the shopping to do doing,
coming up,
I can type a date during the Irvine Improv on the 30th and 31st of January.
That was the first time.
Like,
I used to think that like,
uh,
the real housewives of Orange County.
I said,
okay,
all right.
They pick like some extreme people from down here.
And I went down there and I did it.
And like I saw like nine people that had like back when Bruce was Bruce the
Bruce Jenner fucking I jobs like walking around the mall and they all had like
those laminated phase like in my eyes were watering,
looking at them like going like they look like something like that.
He had it hot wax on there.
You don't look younger.
You just look like that face what you're talking about.
The polled and the lips that are so smooth and shine.
The neck always gives your way.
Of course.
You know what's weird though is if you,
if you keep working out and like your body can stay looking young but your head,
I don't know what the fuck it is with your head.
It's like no sit ups or anything for your head.
Like I don't know,
he keeps you ahead and shape what your head just gives it away.
That's the ring on the fucking,
I think cause it's outside your shirt.
Like the rest of your body's like cover it up.
This is just taking the weather.
Hey,
will you put up that picture of Dennis,
the guy from cat house?
The pimp.
Oh yeah,
I bet.
Gifts page.
Great.
Gimps like when those,
that whole zipped up fucking leather so preserved and they're under the floor.
It's like there been a human wine cellar all day.
But Dennis is a great example of that stuff.
Super White White Veneer.
Uh Yeah.
He looks like shit.
You got your,
if you get the super white veneer then you have to get the fake Tan.
Then you've got something that you start when you start wearing like you know
the guys who keep wearing tank,
like guys who keep wearing tank tops past a certain age.
It's like the only way that works is if you totally Jack are,
you're a fat fuck.
But if you just have like those,
those old arms,
just like this is what he looked like before he got them.
Okay.
So this is,
this is just regular teeth.
Like you just look like a regular street that watching fucking sick.
I love that watch.
And everybody who doesn't know this is the bunny ranch owner of the famous bunny
ranch owner has the,
the the show was,
it was called cat house.
Yeah.
It was on HBO for a show called whorehouse.
It's cat house bell.
It's different.
It's human trafficking house that was taken.
There's a lot of fun.
It's a lot of shows out there.
We run out a name.
It's like you to name a standup special mouth,
like,
oh,
it's the worst.
That was the worst experience.
The latest one.
I don't know.
The first two are easy for me to name.
Couldn't name the third one.
I just was like sending in submissions and I was like,
what do you think of these six titles?
No,
I didn't know what to say.
I didn't know what to call it.
You've named them.
Well,
you've had good names.
Oh,
thank you.
Walk your way.
Okay.
Here's his latest one.
Looks totally different.
Oh yes.
Hold on.
I'm trying to find him.
I'm trying to find a way to go.
Yeah,
that's a problem,
Bill.
Is that those red flags?
I just find him so endearing.
My husband and I.
Those are not,
those are crazy.
Those are crazy teeth.
Yeah,
and the thing is too,
like what?
What you supposed to do that?
I worked in a dental office with my dad for a while.
What you're supposed to do is when you've fixed somebody's,
it's supposed to be subtle like cause they totally,
it not only did they whiten them up and they obviously fixed that chipped tooth
as what you would want to do a little composite action there on number nine.
I'm sorry it's all coming back to eat.
They totally changed the alignment of the teeth and then there's so perfect,
you know like you want somebody whose yard is so landscape like you know you're
not supposed to walk on it.
It's like you literally can't walk on the grass.
Like you can't have teeth like that.
You can't,
you can't.
I guess you can because I have the nearest my two friends cause I knocked and
one of them out as a kid they say they'd have to be at somewhat translucent
light has to go through them.
So when the people get them they look like chiclets when they're just white,
white wine and like just like bricks and your mouth.
That's when they lived terribly.
Get them like glass or something.
This is the craziest Mozzarella balls like could do just like shape,
pretty solid heavy on the MOOC there.
The uh,
the craziest one.
I've,
I saw
this natural teeth,
Danny Aiello,
Danny,
his teeth match the age of the face.
That's his.
Yeah.
So his is like,
here's his normal,
this is like his man.
What a great actor by the way.
But come on these new ones.
I mean,
those are nuts.
Those are crazy.
Here's the thing,
did they make you know about why they make veneers now that will be like,
oh,
there'll be nice,
but they'll,
they'll have like normal,
uh,
color I'm saying,
but like,
that's super white.
What is that?
Is that maybe like a porcelain?
He just went like a straight,
what is it?
It's probably having his bathroom redundant.
They had some leftover material.
I don't know.
I don't want to make fun of this guy's guy's fucking great.
I know.
I'm just saying,
I'm not trying to make fun of me saying that the teeth replacement didn't go
well.
Let me just think it's too white.
When's the last time you went to the dentist?
I,
last month.
I'm actually doing Invisalign right now.
Good for you.
Because I,
you know,
I never had braces.
I just lucked out that they came in pretty straight.
But as you get older,
like I dunno,
like your jaw keeps growing and stuff and stuff started.
I was thinking this guy's,
you know,
and they took a three d model of put my teeth we're going to look like and
stuff.
And he scared the shit out of me.
It's like I was going to pick Mr Ed psych.
Okay.
Bold redhead and haven't fucking Freddie Mercury smile.
I can't have that.
So it's 16 weeks of these things and uh,
I'm about seven weeks and so,
okay.
And then at the rest of your life,
you just at night you just wear a night guard,
which is fine cause I grind my teeth anyways cause I,
even when I sleep by stress,
like I gotta get this done.
So,
um,
yeah.
Now had you had your wisdom teeth removed?
Yeah.
Oh,
so that,
I thought that would prevent that from happening,
but apparently not.
No.
I just noticed down here they were just getting more and more and it was funny,
like I,
I thought like,
uh,
it was these that were the problem is actually behind was like pushing on them
and like it's pretty amazing though.
But every,
every,
every week like you put a new one in like on Wednesday,
so that fucking hearts you on Wednesday.
Right.
And they,
it just move it just incrementally.
It's Nice,
you know,
considering like at the point the age that I'm at,
everything is slowly tapering off.
It's nice to have something going in like a positive direction.
So can you eat with them energy?
God,
no.
You have to take them out and then you got to brush your teeth and floss because
his animals,
and I know,
I know,
it's just like if you do that for a week like that,
it's not,
it's no longer Invisalign.
It's like,
oh,
I saw you had to eat for the rest of the whole week.
It's like a retainer.
I had braces and retainers.
It's similar.
You have a nice dentition is how it's said.
Let me see what you got going on that there.
That's not back.
I've never had braces anything.
But they couldn't be wiping his bottom teeth.
No.
That's when he could go somewhere between what you got in.
Danny's got really to see your bottom teeth when you smile but,
but look hot.
But you never even see his bottom teeth when he talks.
When he does his bottom lip is so big I feel or what is that the fuck man?
Yeah.
Layoff.
I don't see yours when you talk.
Yeah.
Say So.
No,
no,
no.
You're trying and are you thinking about your mouth?
I'm going to steal a look.
You can still look camera.
I can see both years cause I got this fucking mouth guard and my mouth and I'm
also not a good looking person.
We've,
we've established this.
Alright,
let me right there.
You can't see it.
Well that's silly smile.
That's not a deliberate is that I said cause you grew up a wrestling fan.
Yeah.
Do you know about this?
Like,
there's like the,
you know,
whatever the single a league of wrestling,
like this is like a like guys that like wrestling and kind of do amateur style.
Oh,
cool.
Um,
open mic rustling open.
My wrestling is the best way to describe it.
And you're speaking of speech patterns.
So this was sent in as an interesting speech pattern.
This guy named Lou Jean.
I'm just going to throw it to you and I want you to give your opinions and your
feelings said about you.
Listen up Lou Jane,
this fright trying.
I seent your video.
What you call on you too about me and stuff.
They ain't going to happen to me on July 27.
Listen Up.
You're ugly.
Short part.
You ain't got to take this belt from me.
Lou Jane.
I'm sure you're old school.
I ask where I represent you from old school.
Just a new school.
Lou Jane.
Is that the real life?
CLEVELAND?
It feels like it,
right?
It sounds like,
you know what I,
I would definitely watch this and I love this fucking village people guy on the
fucking left.
That's his promoter.
GGL.
I actually could be a stunt double for him.
I'm not.
You could that it's worked out though.
Yeah.
Sounds like Forrest Gump.
He has like a such a terrific speech pattern.
You know that listen up [inaudible] I don't think,
I don't think he's putting it on.
I don't know.
I know that guy.
He's a scary dude because he's,
Tony didn't yell and because it was calm and he's a big guy like that guy.
I think when the bell rings he might not hear it and you might keep going.
What happened?
What happened there?
I just want him to kill,
heal something beautiful.
I was at fight club moment.
Everybody was talking about,
I saw that movie once of mice and men.
That's what it reminds me.
Oh yeah.
Remember he loves them so much that he kills them all and he's like,
I was hugging it.
Did you cry when you read it,
like you finally related to somebody?
Yes,
I did.
I got really emotional actually in that.
I've never read it.
No,
no.
This is a few things.
Like I am a movie that was saw Willy Wonka and the chocolate factory till I was
like 40 Oh really?
So then I finally just heard I could weave how dark it was.
I loved it.
I was some kids movie.
Oh my God.
My wife was like,
the other night she goes,
you want to go to the movies?
I was like,
yeah,
let's go the movies.
She goes,
do you want to see like Jumanji like star wars?
And I was like,
no.
She goes,
why not?
I go,
cause I'm going to Delta.
Oh my God,
we're trapped in a board game.
Yeah.
I mean I'm 49 years old.
I can't fucking watch that.
God bless everybody in it.
They made a ton of fucking money.
But that won't be it.
And that movie wasn't for me.
Exactly.
So that would be,
I've watched this take this belt from me,
Lou Jane.
I hate seeing fucking bomber movies.
Like you want to see the movie about the guy who's got cancer?
Oh yeah.
Kind of a fucking watch this for two hours or white bummers right.
It's always love bombing and feel like it's a white person.
White people are like,
and then the baby had cancer that Casey Affleck,
where we wait is performance is amazing.
I fucking had to get up and walk out.
I said Manchester by the sea.
Fuck.
I would never see that.
But we got,
God,
I don't even have a kid at that point.
I don't even want no,
no,
no.
They all came in.
The screeners all came in last year we got the stack and we were like white
bummer,
white bomber wipe bump,
and then it was moonlight.
We're like,
that's a black bumper.
Cars since moonlight was like aids and like,
I don't want to watch any of these.
You know?
It's funny,
I saw moon moon.
I think like,
I think I'm gonna sit and with lighting,
I know it's supposed to be the,
I know I saw that and I have no idea how it ends.
Really.
I can never remember him.
No,
I can't.
I'm a,
when I saw the usual suspects,
I,
I daydreamed in the middle of it.
All right.
It's like massive,
crazy add back then like I lost focus so I didn't really pay attention.
So when the end cap and everyone was like freaking out around me and I was just
like,
I don't have,
I go,
whatever,
I won't,
I won't remember the movie,
so I'll be able to go back and go see it again.
But what happened was it became such a legendary movie that everybody said,
Oh my God,
the ending.
So I,
I,
I you put it together.
No,
no,
no.
I was never able to go back.
Oh,
and then,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I want to,
as it was happening,
I was like,
oh,
so this was all right.
I'm telling you to ruin it for anybody.
I understood what happened,
but I didn't,
I wasn't on the ride.
Did you enjoy moonlight?
If that's what it's called?
Yeah,
I did.
Yeah.
I really liked that movie.
Like I like,
I like movies where I,
I think like,
okay,
that would happen,
that that's a natural reaction,
blah,
blah.
Like,
I either want it to be like totally over the top,
blowing everything up or just an absurd comedy or like something that seems like
this is really happening.
That's shit that exists in the middle that passes itself off as like a real
gritty movie and it's just like people not holding guns right and shit like
this.
Stuff like that.
And it starts to annoy me after one.
Yeah.
I like grounded.
I like grounded comedies where it's like,
it's not big studio comedy of like,
you know,
like in the nice guys.
Yeah.
One of my favorite fucking movie.
Ryan Gosling and Russell Crowe.
Russell Crowe.
I was a good movie.
I love that movie.
I like those types of like dark comedies.
But then I just,
honestly,
the only thing I really want to see that I really go for our thrillers.
I love suspense.
I love like a political thriller.
I love murder,
mystery,
all that stuff that's entertainment to me.
I hate horror films.
Horror.
I'm not entirely,
I just hate having the shit skate on it cause I always take the ride on them.
Yeah.
Like everyone.
Blair witch came out and it was like,
that didn't scare me.
That movie scared the shit out of me.
Really.
I did a set at the laugh factory and I went and I saw the midnight showing by
myself and later on and I walked into the parking garage by myself.
I mean,
I was waiting to see some dude standing in the corner facing the wall freaks you
out.
That did the ring freaked me out.
Uh,
I,
what was that Baba dog?
Dog.
Do you ever see that fucking one?
No,
I forget that.
That fucking,
and this is nothing to,
I will literally,
I literally get angry if there is a horror movie and this some kid,
little kid in trouble.
Uh,
like I get mad at the movie like foot.
Not for the fuck would I want to watch this.
We just started dark.
It'd be something you watch on Netflix,
but the serious chairman to chairman series,
it's a big hit of you.
You know,
you haven't seen it though.
I'm going to watch a German horror move.
No,
no,
no.
It's a series.
It's the monster shit on somebody.
It's like a stranger things,
but German kind of,
but there is a kid that goes missing.
I can't,
I can't watch it.
What was I going to fucking say?
You know,
we started watching law and order special victims unit
don't even show me.
How did it go from happy days to that I know special victims unit,
which is like,
these are the most egregious violence,
sexual crimes,
and it's a series.
It's like crazy.
You know,
we started watching on Netflix,
everyone shit on and we were actually enjoying,
is that movie bright?
The new the Will Smith movie?
I want to see that we're halfway through it.
I was expecting like a hate watch,
like a ha ha.
It's entertaining.
I never do that.
Yeah.
I think that's bad Karma to watch something.
Anything artistic,
you're gonna Watch it because it sucks as a few of them.
I guess I can just watch that wrestling thing,
but like,
I don't do that cause I feel bad for the people,
especially if it's a guy like,
you know,
who's had great movies.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And you know,
sometimes they just don't come together,
right.
Yeah.
So,
um,
but her good guy,
man,
you have a lot empathy.
Yeah,
I do.
Yeah.
I actually do as much as much content as I am.
I actually,
you know,
I don't,
but this is my thing.
I don't like kicking somebody when they're down.
I don't,
but I'm sure you could go back in my act.
I'm sure I'm guilty of it.
I'm also a hypocrite though.
So they got there you go there.
You got a cell phone on it before.
So billboard,
it's funny.
He said,
oh,
I got it.
Irvine dates.
Of course they're all sold out.
Um,
you can see him in Christ in the fold them again.
And Reno,
Reno Ballroom,
Santa Barbara,
the Arlington Theater.
He's going to do the Patrice O'Neal benefit in New York.
February 20th.
That's right.
Only a few tickets left.
You're going to be in Vancouver.
And uh,
even we just added a show there.
Check it out,
try it out,
check it out,
try it out.
Can I do,
what'd you rather with though?
Oh,
of course.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Let's do it.
Get to a movie,
other music and yeah,
I don't know.
Okay.
Would you rather smile and only show your bottom teeth or have to get the worst
boob job ever?
Ah,
have the smile
clearly.
The top layer,
chunk compose this music.
Somebody married.
There's times by my buddy John Sex with your sister.
They the face grandmother,
Washington on you masturbating.
Never have another orgasm
intro with it long enough.
It's going to be a little bit longer.
Hold on.
What's it now?
Okay.
Ready?
Here we go.
Would you rather,
this is just specific for you.
I crafted this one just for you.
Okay.
Would you rather from now on,
you're known as the non-binary comedian Bill Burr Hen,
right?
I love this already.
I feel like I need to reinvent myself at this point in my career.
So I like this so far.
And you're kind of going to do an Eddie Izzard thing where you maybe you want,
you might wear like high heels and a skirt for the first half of your show and
then you might gender flux in the middle of your set and then go back to being a
man.
What does gender flux mean?
Good question.
So gender is fluid,
wasn't condescending at all
genders fluid.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it can,
it can change throughout the course of the hour.
The 10 head,
could it be she to start the show and he,
by the end of the show,
you could be asked for someone to take them on a bright color gender.
It could be dog and [inaudible] mission,
which I think would be advisable.
Where you switch genders.
So like your first half,
like she said as an address,
maybe you can pick the shoes.
Can they have like the ones that don't hurt your back?
The one with the less sexy or stiletto one big square one.
Oh,
right.
Yeah.
Wedges.
I'm going to a barn raising.
Yeah,
true.
Okay.
So you're the nonbuyer,
your bill burr,
the non-binary comedians are in right now,
or your bill burr,
the race comedian,
where you do kind of what Don Rickles and Lisa Lampanelli we're doing,
you know,
so it's like,
aw man,
a Puerto Rican guy in the front and once with the go clean,
the hotel rooms connect.
Can I do it as like a Tony Clifton type character or do I have to believe it?
Well,
you know it's you.
I know.
No,
no,
he gave you,
this is a character.
It's not,
you're no longer bill burr the race.
I would do the binder.
Everything.
Absolutely.
Really?
So you can do it all the material you want,
but your presentation will just be as Hen I absolutely.
I probably have more female fans by Mike fucking fan bases,
a sausage fest.
You know,
maybe have that prince vibe,
but he's in drudging us.
Yeah,
that's true.
So you'd go for that too.
Some of my jokes and false settle.
Fuck yeah.
Here you go.
Learn a couple of languages.
Okay.
He's in.
I her in a dress and heels and not addressing it would be the fucking,
most of them.
You can't be like this is because Chris soap soap.
Would you rather,
it would be so brave.
So courageous.
So woke woke a f,
you know what I mean?
Coming out.
Okay,
so you're the nonbinary comedian.
Very good.
Good.
Here's another one in Irvine.
By the way up.
They didn't mention,
I'm going to be wearing a dress.
Yes,
please.
Okay.
What'd you rather?
Everywhere you go,
you have to run to get there.
I'm out on that one.
I don't even care what the next one is.
My back can't take it.
It's literally like you go to the next room in your house to say exactly like
always running.
Never stretching,
just always running.
You have to run somebody that someone knocked on your front door.
You have to run there to run on stay heavy fees,
Rome,
boom,
boom.
I don't care what this or join isis.
Isis,
let's get those fucking infidels.
Or every time you speak you're shouting.
So you're basically a toddler that you're just your soul volume.
Well,
it hurt my voice to Doris A.
Little bit.
Of course.
Ah.
Either of these are going to be fun.
You have to go like the phone.
Hello?
Yeah.
You always say everything in that range and your standup.
I find a loophole.
The loophole.
I would just ignore people.
Oh,
so then I wouldn't have to talk to them when they,
I just wait till they saved my name 10 times.
Then I'd be like,
why?
So it makes sense.
It's a loophole because you need,
you need your health,
you need your health.
In a way I buy my body would just hurt so much.
If you love be like bail,
you got to go.
Yeah.
And then she's like,
do you think you get her daughter to the park?
You're like,
yeah.
And then your sweet daughter.
But I could explain to go
in a tone of my voice.
I love you more than life itself.
You're my best friend.
So
what's,
you're going to have to do the purchase
Westboro during the movie?
Yeah.
He could shout it.
It's one of my favorite actors.
Yeah,
definitely.
I think could do it.
Yep.
I actually would that,
that would be fun.
Why is my wife was into it.
I would just be totally quiet
and you're having sex.
You're like,
dad,
you bounce off.
It would wear on her
after awhile.
I would just stop.
Take a pillow around my mouth.
Right.
It's still hard.
It's still not sexy.
No,
no brainer.
Terrible back in my head.
But if you run it everywhere,
you'd be in great shape.
There you go.
And You can maintain your,
your human relationships.
Yeah.
You wouldn't yell at it,
but it's,
it's as simple as like you have to go piss in the middle of the night
to
go,
but I would be miserable.
I would start yelling at people because your body can't take that.
Yeah,
that'd be a lot.
But you get used to it.
What do you mean you'd be getting in fantastic shape?
I would just love to see.
That's all you need to be in.
Fantastic shape and you'd run everywhere and you don't get used to it.
Your body breaks down.
Then he goes into the bank runs,
so the line,
they're like your next sprint up.
Hey,
just wanting to make a deposit and they're like,
all right,
chill the fuck out.
Run up to the TSA line.
I'll be fucking amazed.
Every time I have to start flying private,
please split sprinting through the airport.
So you're going to take shouting?
Uh,
it made me laugh.
So yeah,
I would take shower.
I told you I just,
I wouldn't talk to people a lot.
Yeah,
just ignore everyone.
What's your act?
You're going to have to shout to start writing books and I would live alone.
He couldn't do the audible version of the book though.
Just to read your people.
I after awhile I went up to talk to,
but yeah.
Then what?
If I want those hard ones,
I'm maybe I would choose running
neat.
Neither what?
I think I kill myself.
Either one of those would lead me to suicide.
That's the point.
The show.
Tom,
what would you choose?
Running or yelling?
Yelling.
Look at him.
He's completely out of shape.
I have not.
I run,
I lift weights.
No,
you're done.
I swear to you.
I have to do.
I always do.
You should feel bad about yourself.
Phil.
I've been doing aiming you shaming me?
I could do it more.
She you all right?
Uh,
yeah.
Husky.
No,
like in the 70s when they used to have that size husky rescue Jane's.
Yeah.
You'd be a Husky when you were a boy.
You're a Vicky.
Vicky.
Yeah.
Thick boy nation.
That's what I'm part of
the ICC.
Um,
no,
I would definitely not take running.
I would yell at everybody.
I would take running,
maybe not pregnant,
but if I were pregnant,
I just run everywhere we good for you get my,
I hate exercise.
Yeah.
No,
that was what I'd get it out of the way.
It'd be insane.
You'd feel a sense of urgency.
They both make you feel unsafe,
but I take,
I was shouting,
run into yoga class,
then run out like crazy man.
But they'd also be crazy if you're like,
I'm ready to die,
you know?
Feeling good.
All right.
Yeah.
You could hide the having to run everywhere more.
I bill,
can you come here for a second?
I busy.
Yeah,
exactly.
I said come here for a second.
Not in a second.
Yeah.
Go to commercial.
Boom,
there's your sick.
This might be a sick comp.
It could be these two people live together.
Dude.
I like it.
Well,
yeah,
I'll stop running if we stopped shouting.
We can't.
We played.
Would you rather so we're stuck in this agreement?
Yeah.
That's the steak.
If you want to move in,
you come like the fucking,
that guy's fascinating.
I want to hear him talk about other shit though.
I don't know.
It's global warming.
I don't know if he's going to come.
Does that itching?
That's all I got.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
Um,
Bill,
thanks a lot for coming over here.
Much a great time with you as always.
Um,
I love what it says and they shit that you do.
Yeah,
no,
just look at it.
You're the psycho.
Look on your face as you say.
This is fucking great.
Everything is psycho from me.
I didn't realize that.
And he's right.
Bill bird.com for your tickets to have to all his saying [inaudible] fuck me.
And um,
yeah,
you can listen to his wonderful podcast,
the Monday morning podcast.
Uh,
you could watchF is for family.
It's on Netflix.
He has 13 a standup comedy specials.
Hen Hen has their head does.
Now you're on the program.
Good.
Now you're finally getting it.
Finally,
he's all right.
So that's it.
Gene.
Anything else?
That's it.
Go to the site.
Your mom's house.
Try it out so it's not that I'm cheap.
It's this,
that this is going to exist in the ocean forever,
so I might as well fucking drink it right?
There you go.
Try it out.
Yeah,
piss.
Somebody beat me.
All right.
Bye guys.
Thanks so much.
James Jeans.
The day before the 70th birthday on again,
they got to have a swinging time.
Get a grip upon the poll.
I'm going downtown to in the water and gonna have our sale to 69 69 69
beat.
That's
the
one downtown to the watering hole of our sales to 69.